[Applaudissements]
tony rage avec nous attention la
première réponse et des mots crus des
mots crus des mots crus des mauvais
gagnent les mots crus oui qu'est ce
qu'on a pu entendre dans plus belle la
vie huawei à point pour lier aux gens
sont sensibles aux argentins gagne
encore ce soir ouais je vous le dis je
retire 20 bal du salaire de tout le
monde je voulais mais je ne rigole pas
il faut réduire et tribus et à guillaume
genton car ça fait trois fois de suite
qu'ils gagnent alors guillaume genton
donc plus belle la vie qu'est ce qui
s'est passé en fait il ya eu en fait
c'est un extrait qui a été publié sur
twitter avec des mots particulièrement
crues ou des adolescents parlent de sexe
ouvertement dans une série qui passent
l'après midi sur france 3 alors c'est le
soir un oui en fin d'après midi début de
soirée
qu'ils veulent et value de la
regarder
ah ouais genre jean rennes il kiffe
qu'elle le doute pendant qu'il la laisse
si j'ai encore mieux lola qui fut
faciale fait ça t'en avec ta meuf bien
sûr
trop pensé mais bien sûr que non ah là
j'en ai des choses te dit elle pendant
les chattes quoi quand tu sais l éponge
ça c'est des choses à ce
nom mais samba sur france 3 oui mais oui
c'est pas les spectateurs sont
tranquillement sur les éditions
régionales
là ils sortent de cela avec leur fille
mustier
pirates quant à ses bustiers et
intuitivement et là c'est tout chat et
tutti
continuer
avec moi je veux bien je veux bien que
france 3 après le virage mais qui nous
conviennent avant la brand est content
ou pas ils sont là ils sortent de ça
derrière c'est la truite argenté sur
thalassa
fera le coeur bien accroché nan mais
sans déconner mais pas ma part et quoi
là mais c'est la marque de fabrique de
plus belle la vie
j'adore passer de dire on colle au plus
près de la façade ou d'ailleurs les les
écritures qui sont vraiment la veille
pour le lendemain il tourne vraiment
très très rapidement ils sont toujours
sur l'actualité ils font des choses au
fur et à mesure donc là ils ont ils ont
voulu dire ben on est on est au plus
près de ce qu'ils auront croiser ou post
massés dans des pistes et donc ça va
delphine est ce que ça vous choque moi
ça me choque le gars qui écrit le texte
effectivement la veille pour le
lendemain et ben oui ça se passe comme
ça chez les jeunes aujourd'hui
weeb0
novembre avec nous le 20 septembre bah
oui mais de montrer ça vraiment que
effectivement 2021 les jeunes parlent
comme ça font des trucs comme ça à
l'école franchement c'est chaud quand ça
va mal mais ça n'avance trois ils ont
entendu ce mot là ils étaient persuadés
qu'ils étaient tous sur 30 millions
d'amis nation
non mais en fait c'est décrit la tournée
sur twitter et comme d'habitude sur
twitter les gens ils ont jugé la
regardant 30 secondes alors que c'est un
épisode qui parle du cyber assidu au
cyber-centre c'est autour de la
sexualité et donc ils sont bien obligés
d'illustrer sa avec des vraies
conversations d'intéressant et les
adolescents il parle comme ça
aujourd'hui évidemment c'est pas une
cenne graby oui ça me permet de
descendre
ça permet de désamorcer puisque la
preuve qu'on voit derrière par exemple
évidemment après va prendre le problème
à bras le corps si j'ose dire et ça va
être ça va être réglé d'ailleurs tous
les feuilletons que ce soit là dedans où
que ce soit tf1 ont été encensés entre
guillemets par le ministère de la santé
pour ni retraités nom de la société
mais qui traitait vraiment des problèmes
maternité
j'ai près d'accord du tout avec isabelle
je m'en fous plus plus belle famille
lebel l'apli c'est une émission qui a la
carte ça c'est de les trouver mais si
oui voilà il tempéré si vous voulez si
c'était une autre série ça ne passerait
pas mais comme ces oeufs ont dit
vendredi il ya un prétexte sociétal donc
pourquoi pas m'arrêter je viens de loin
comme ça tu regardes plus belle la vie
tony je regarde où s'arrête à buguma
même moi je regarderai des mois le site
quand tu es dedans tu regardes à je te
jure à moyen terme bien sûr c'est que tu
te laisses prendra bien sûr après ben
voilà il crête de problème aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que voilà c'est un problème
qui est en tout cas ici franchement plus
belle la vie ils réagissent sur
l'actualité parce que c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont formés à la sandale dans ses
téléspectateurs la vie oui à sannois 52%
et oui à 47 pendant c'est assez dit
aimer ses 52 voilà donc merci c'est vous
qui avez été la plus convaincante
isabelle je déconnais réponse 30,2
millions d'euros 32 millions d'euros et
qu'elle est la question s'il vous plaît
il quel est le salaire annuel de messi
au psg pas du tout bas valais révéler
quel est le prix de la voiture de messi
n'ont alors pas tout à fait ça mais le
prix de la voiture la plus chère de la
collection
[Applaudissements]
alors ça c'est passé une petite fée des
voitures mais je crois qu'il ya un mec
qui équipent les voitures c'est lionel
messi le nouveau joueur du psg à
quelques voitures dans sa collection il
a pour combien je crois 55 55 il ya dix
ans une voiture il a 55 millions d'euros
de voitures qu'est-ce qui peut valoir 32
millions sur l'incroyable de gatineau
c'est une ferrari de 1953 est incroyable
exactement banon on n lamborghini
[Rires]
regardez
il a acheté une ferrari en 2016 il fait
harry de 1957 il l'a acheté 32 millions
d'euros aux enchères ils ne l'utilisent
pas mais pour lui c'est une espèce de
d'investissement parce qu'il sait très
bien que la voiture qu'il a acheté 32
millions d'euros il pourra la revendre
au moins aussi cher donc c'est quelqu'un
de très très construit au niveau de la
façon dont il vit il n'a pas un train de
vie
bling bling donc c'est quelqu'un de
plutôt sobre dans l'utilisation de son
argent
mais je voudrais juste savoir un petit
pont de voilà c'est monsieur le temps
qui prend le poids
alors donné j ce que tu en penses tony
n'est pas juste comme tony trouve que
c'est pas juste et bien entendu que j'ai
pas envie qui me plaît
bien entendu le point et à valérie
bénaïm tu peux le faire [ __ ]
alors fatalement alors oui non mais
quand on voit ça on a l'impression qu'il
est très dépensiers mais cirque en fait
pas trop
cinquante familles
à la fois j'étais avec lui on a été
prise au ch yens il arrive de la
meilleure
mais c'est un truc de fou je lui prends
une petite paire de saucats
c'est vrai il est comme ça en fait mais
si il est milliardaire donc c'est voilà
pour lui c'est pas grand chose à et pas
comparé à cristiano ronaldo qui sont
éternelles rivales par exemple cristiano
cristiano ronaldo il a deux jets privés
mais s'il n'en a pas il en loup non mais
quand même attention à ses seins way à
part pour les voitures et attention
c'est son
nom
mais c'est son seul qui sait les
voitures voilà oui d'accord oui sur
l'immobilier excusez moi il fait des
recherches il investit là quand il est
venu à paris ses saillies it had les
gens pour avoir les plus belles
résidences faut pas dire non plus que
messier quelqu'un qui est par nous les
yeux bienveillants mais les achats nous
alors n'hésitez pas si vous le dire mais
c'est d'ailleurs ce soir un documentaire
réalisé par guillaume genton ce soir à
22h sur ces huit en deuxième partie de
soirée c'est moi qui produit oui comme
quoi les regarder la
[Rires]
france
autre extrait du documentaire de surnam
ici sur les infidélités de mode mi6
apparemment il serait infidèle
regarder
avant
sa vie aussi c'était avant qu avant
maintenant ils voient plus rien
jo ann alès est une playmate qui a
prétendu avoir une histoire avec
lionel messi enfin une histoire avoir
passé une nuit avec en donnant des
détails ne mettant pas forcément en
valeur lionel messi et ses qualités
lors de cette nuit passée ensemble
oui j'ai couché avec lionel messi si ça
se trouve il ne se rappelle même plus de
mon nom ce fut une belle nuit mais j'ai
éprouvé le sentiment d'avoir couché avec
un mort
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on a
conduit qu'au projet moi qui produit sa
très belle émission que c'est quand même
pour ça
il est réputé pour être très fidèle avec
sa femme antonella et là c'est une femme
qui aurait été payé pour dire ça c'est
ce qu'on dit après elle aurait pris
quatorze mille euros pour dire cette
histoire qui a priori sera inventé donc
c'est des rumeurs aient été relayées
mais à priori il est très fidèle ou le
dit ça dans le dock bien sûr on me dit
je suis même très bien alors voilà qui
s'est produite rue pour avoir des procès
après
[Rires]
des spectateurs très beaux dunks en tout
cas avant le croiseur inédit main sur
lionel messi ce soir oui ok school et
vous faites une pause comme ça parce que
nous avons évidemment parce que c'est
bizarre ça veut dire quoi à coucher avec
la mort quels sentiments mais qui
bougeait pas prévisible
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
chacun sa spécialité dans les poches
morts merde je sais que je n'ai pas
c'est faux ce que vous dites mais ça
avait une époque quand j'avais pas envie
lui les fais ce que tu veux moi je dors
elle a écouté ça donne envie
mais c'est vrai ça donne envie
les ché réponse la réponse à ces tickets
gagnants ticket gagnant oui et non car
aussi si donc appris un buraliste à une
pauvre dame à naples mais ça va être
très bonne réponse mais la réponse a
pris un buraliste
[Applaudissements]
d'accord le point
bas les devises
[Applaudissements]
attention voix data sacrée tuile au
champagne tout ce que ça veut dire
aujourd hui 12e alors c'est une histoire
de fou que s'est passé en italie une
femme avait gagné cinq cent mille euros
au loto et voilà elle allait poser son
ticket gagnant chez le buraliste sauf
que là le but l'art et le réalisme qui
voit qu'il a gagné 500 millions il prend
un ticket gagnant et il se barre avec
non mais sans déconner ce qui est fou
c'est que c'est pas qu'il est barré avec
c'est que carrément il est il a fui il a
pris son casque de moto sur twitter il
s'est barricadé et alors on a les
coordonnées monsieur serait apparemment
bernardo monde qu'elle a
grandi dernier à naples une retraitée se
présente dans un bureau de tabac et
achètent de chicken jeux à gratter le
premier ne donne rien mais en grattant
le deuxième bingo un gain de 500 mille
euros que le buraliste qui pratiquait en
main mais au lieu de le rendre à la
retraité il attrape son casque et saute
sur son scooter voilà il disparaît et
l'histoire a pris fin hier quand la
police a annoncé l'arrestation du
fugitif à rome il était sur le point
d'embarquer sur un vol en direction des
canaries quant au ticket gagnant et bien
il avait pris le temps de le déposer
dans une banque où il comptait en fait
encaisser son gant plus tard quand les
choses se seraient un peu calmé
finalement il va être poursuivi pour vol
aggravé
sécurité dans touche pas à mon pote
rigolant se détendant et en voyant des
gens bizarres oui alors moi il m'est
arrivé la même chose si on était à juan
les pins mais j'étais à côté j'étais
avec ma meilleure amie on a les deux
lorrains n'ont
mode je l'embrassais on est allé dans un
labrune avec les yeux bleus oui
exactement beaucoup
analyse dans un bureau de tabac on a
acheté des magazines et à prendre a dit
tiens si on prenait un ticket à gratter
et moi vraiment c'est le truc que j'ai
pas l'habitude de faire donc du coup on
a gratté devant la buraliste les
premières cases on n'avait rien gagné
bah on a dit bon ok on rend les tickets
sauf que après par la suite on nous a
dit qu'il ya toujours des petits de
cowes bonus sur les cases bonus
exactement du coup dix minutes non cinq
minutes après on retourne
cinq minutes après on retourne et on dit
excusez moi madame on vous a rendu les
tickets n'en a pas gratter le truc bonus
oui donc je dis donc où sont les tickets
donc là elle commença à bafouiller et
tous et elle dit
non elle a dit je les ai mis à la
poubelle et cette poubelle je les vis
des non j'ai dit ok bon c'était il ya
cinq minutes donc voilà du coup je
sentais qu'il énonce entourloupe j'ai
dit vous l'avez vie d où cette poubelle
mdi bas dans la grande poubelle là bas
donc on va voir dans la grande poubelle
dans la rue
jean-talon tholot ont louvre elle était
vide j'ai dit mais elle est vide elle
m'a dit oui mais je pense qu'un camion
poubelle a dû passer
veuille éloignez les enfants
c'est terrible a fait jamais ça seul
alors oui en gros elle a commencé à
trembler à rougir et tous mes achats
quand on a ouvert sa claque c'était vide
vous comprenez vite donc ça voudrait
dire qu'un camion pick qu'elle a jeté sa
en 5 minutes ou un camion poubelle et
pincer pour récupérer oui voilà alors
j'ai dit mais bon vaut caméras elles
peuvent montrer que vous avons été
almadies mes caméras sont en panne bon
bref donc tout ça pour dire je pense que
je suis millionnaire enfin qu'elle est
millionnaire et qu'elle a pris mon
ticket
si vous voulez être millionnaire c'est
très simple un short l écueil nicolas
mais lui par contre rien à gratter
[Applaudissements]
mais j'avais beaucoup aimé l'histoire
des prix mais alors que je n'étais pas
dans le best-of
toujours gratter tous les bonus et
toujours les emmener en snacks en france
est arrivé il ya un monsieur qui a donné
son ticket de loto donc aux buralistes
et u10 dont vous n'avez rien gagné et en
fait comme il jouait toujours les mêmes
numéros il a rejoint la semaine d'après
la semaine d'après la semaine après donc
en fait la française des jeux a compris
à se dit mais pourquoi ce monsieur
pourquoi ça qu'on joue là nos
combinaisons qui est tombé la semaine
dernière sous la main oui ça m'est
arrivé aussi non mais ça non ce n'est
qu'en fait elle l'apprend la française
des jeux
j'étais jeune et beau
jeu tous les défauts
[Applaudissements]
suis un côté jeu et
côté
la française des jeux s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait un problème et elle a
compris que ce monsieur avait été volé
parce qu'ils jouent et chacune des
numéros les mêmes chaque semaine on peut
pas rejouer de nouveau 'qe' ceux qui
sont tombés ils ont mené l'enquêté on a
rendu son titre
[Rires]
contre 2 dont je pense que c'est
l'argent de regarder deux cent mille
spectateurs
aucun problème quelle est la question
continue la réponse c'est des testeurs
de suppositoire des testeurs de suppose
oui on s'y met avec aston villa oui
absolument
puis 6
alors arrêtez oui un échantillon a été
choisi pour une question et battez les
quais pour qu'elles pour quelle maladie
non mais non c'est bon ca question c'est
plus le support
tel est le nouveau job pour lequel jean
reçu de l'argent
du président soit ça va tuer les
ailes et le nouveau job pour laquelle
des gens ont été payés par les apports
lequel les gens là-bas la sas et bien
non ouais j'aurais bien voulu lui donner
l'épaisseur président macky l'institut
pasteur fait appel pour trouver un
traitement contre le co lead alors ben
ali à qui l'institut pasteur fait-il
appel
[Applaudissements]
ouais chez vous j'ai caressé français
c'est bien celle au carré frais
chérie on courait depuis quelques temps
maintenant les essais des laboratoires
concernant les vaccins on vient de
découvrir autre chose l'institut pasteur
recherche en ce moment des cobayes pour
tester des suppôts regardez c'est un
suppositoire dans lequel il ya du clos
fin octobre
c'est tout cela que le facteur bien sûr
c'est comme le bihac tonnes mais n'a pas
les blues ont battu
[Rires]
de cinq jours avec un suppositoire le
matin un suppositoire le soir et c'est
cette forme qui paraît un peu anciennes
à peu désuète a beaucoup d'intérêt c'est
que elle elle est très très rapidement
absorbée et la course quand le virus est
une course contre la montre il est très
rapide et le fait d'avoir une absorption
extrêmement rapide et un début de
traitement efficace en quelques heures
c'est un gros avantage contre ce virus
oui oui vous avez dans quel sens il faut
le mettre de suppositoire
j'ai appris ça n'y a pas longtemps
c'est en fait parce que c'était le côté
arrondi non c'est de l'autre côté nature
parce que c'est comme ça et après comme
ça
c'est ça parce que c'est vrai quand vous
êtes attaque non mais sérieux c'est le
mec comme ça de côté comme ça
t'attendais dérange t pas
mais on vous a entendu de mesures ils
disent que les suppositoires pour peu
importe la maladie mais que le supposé
deux c'est mieux c'est
[Rires]
très bien alors je vous le dis
alors je vous dis vous feignez souvent
avec des supposés j'adore
mon ami et très accueillants
pour oui qu'est ce qu'on voit les
accepterait de faire un test non non
non à la fois alors je déteste je ne
sais pas bien tu peux encore depuis des
années des
déchets toujours genève vous connaissez
le micro lac saint quentin n'arrive pas
à aller au chiotte le microlax le matin
quand tu es pressé
tu vois tu es prêt c'est un peu stressé
taille pas faire popo au fait tu te mets
un micro là
comme ses bras oui mais l'avait dit à
mon rythme a commencé
[Applaudissements]
les séries de qui alors question avaler
la question marine le pen marine le pen
je rappelle qu'on est dans lequel est la
question je vous donne la réponse vous
devez mener mais la question
correspondante à l'actualité oui
d'échangé de qui de qui alors marine le
pen je ne veux pas dîné avec eric
zemmour non non mais ça c'est une
information à trois jours sur sept jours
trois heures annoncent toujours la patte
d'oie dont on aurait toujours la page
alors s'il vous plaît de qui de qui oui
on a divulgué le téléphone portable de
cris sur les réseaux sociaux vous parlez
toujours français
allez il faut remettre ça dans la sava
castaldi l'a neutralisé le jeu
toulousain peut
les mecs îles à sion pas sanitaire
secours
venez voir et maintenant il ya un mec
qui tous ont déconné s'ils sont
dans la presse mais total quoi le gaia
tous et la ville attendait non parce que
bon on sait jamais hein tu avais
tellement la scoumoune
aujourd'hui la vérité les gars on arrête
on met les choses au clair ça va très
bien
très bonne mais naim yoplait fait
attention mais sans déconner une
deuxième tentative et ça c'est la
nouvelle année a bien fêté chez toi
c'est pour se retrouver à côté de gens
là mais qui tout ça pue dément comme ça
c'est bon quoi mais sur les collègues
l'envoyer en plus et l'on voit des trucs
ça
il atteint
non mais sans déconner ressaisissez-vous
et maintenant c'est la fontaine de trevi
dans sa demande
et connaissent qu'ils sortent c'est plus
que ses yeux
parasols quelque chose oui je crois
parce que c'est voilà deux qui a t'on
divulguer le numéro de téléphone sur les
réseaux sociaux exactement de la prendre
c'est tt marine le pen avec une belle
terrasse tiers vient d'affecter son
quotidien son numéro de téléphone affûté
sur les réseaux sociaux regardez tous
chaque jour c'est celui du téléphone
portable de marine le pen le numéro de
la candidate à la présidentielle s'est
retrouvé sur internet pendant l'été
occasionnant nombre d'appels d'inconnus
la présidente du fn a donc porté plainte
selon les informations de marie mollet
du service politique de rtl marine le
pen a évidemment changé de numéro de
téléphone j'ai le numéro de marine le
pen nora a baissé de l'appeler thomas
marci toujours le bon marine le pen
marine le pen s'en est allé lui dire
bonjour voilà que c'est parce que je
veux dire je n'avais pas t'as pas
changer de numéro il demandait vraiment
bidon d'eau marine le pen pour l'instant
ça ne sonne pas
marine le pen n'a pas lui non c'est
terminé voilà deux prix nobel ont changé
de numéro on a testé en direct voilà m
et donc c'est vrai c'est fou ça vous le
saviez vous c'est non je ne savais pas
ça décoiffe
lorsqu'il fallait l'appeler
alors oui c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est ça
mais c'est son problème de son les
scieries elles sont trop raciste elles
sont trop raciste c'est la réponse
pourquoi ces oeuvres ont elles été brûlé
au canada quelles oeuvres d art director
de lucky luke et d'astérix à la notation
de genton pourquoi certaines oeuvres ont
été brûlés au canada des heures tintin
lucky luke et astérix c'est guillaume
jean claude
romelo cas n'est plus l'apanage valérie
j'en ai plus rien à carrer m oui c'est
une décision qui crée une grosse
polémique au canada un conseil scolaire
qui rassemble de nombreuses écoles a
pris la décision de virer 5000 livres de
ses collections et donc de les brûler
les livres sont astérix et les indiens
atteinte en amérique plusieurs luttes
ilic de nombreux livres d'enfants sur
les indiens voilà selon eux ces livres
offrait une vision inappropriée des
autochtones amérindiens un biais
d'accords forcément gilbert des
totalement d'accord
il est 3 à 7 sur 10 ce sont des oeuvres
qui sans discriminante notamment pour
les amérindiens et donc il est un
autodafé qui les voit qu'on les
autodafés ils les voient comme des
populations arriérés et donc je trouve
que c'est une bonne décision alors brûlé
on peut discuter mais interdire mille
fois oui mais vous vendez les interdire
avant j'aurais dû me fait je pense que
gilles verdez est un danger public pour
la nuit je suis d'accord c'est un
dictateur tué un dictateur c'est
vraiment il veut pas qu'on éduque les
gens je ne veux pas quoi tu veux juste
qu'on est fan tu veux qu'on les règle
qui veut la cancel culture mieux et
c'est très grave en fait on peut évoluer
mais c'est normal à apprendre on peut
éditer cet aliment ils font la même
chose on va évoquer avec tintin en
amérique et bien justement les dérives
tu peux dire ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
tu peux parler des miracles si non tu
peux ah mais moi j'en suis tant qu'il
veut juste effacé en fait c'est
dramatique tu es le plus intolérant de
nous tous autour de cette année les rend
intolérants autant rien autant moi je
suis contre la quand cette culture comme
dit géraldine autant franchement il ya
certaines de ces bd quand on les lit
aujourd'hui c'est très très très border
on parle de pour rouge quand on
représente des africains comme des
esclaves avec une grosse bouche comme ça
je pense pas que ce soit une superbe
oui mais alors les mêmes qui veulent
supprimer ce genre de choses parlent de
la même chose de la même manière des
films de belmondo parce que regarder
celui demandé non mais les
conventionnels et gif le les femmes
alors à ce moment-là le tapis toi pas
sûr mais le monde sauf que là c'est pour
éduquer les remarquables s'il vous plaît
oui madame je suis très énervé mais moi
quand j'ai revu le signe de belmondo
hier soir je me suis dit ah oui là ça
passerait pas aujourd'hui voilà donc
c'est un appauvrissement de la création
qui est spectaculaire quand vous pensez
que dans le club des cinq on va modifier
le personnage du garçon manqué parce que
ses associés qu'une fille zinc être un
garçon veut imiter un garçon tant qu'on
va appauvrir tous ses albums aussi non
c'est de la folie furieuse envie dans
une époque mais complètement dingue
d'accord mais honnêtement
méchoui la coupe mulet c'est la réponse
la coupe mulet la coupe mulet malgré la
coupe mulet oui qu'est-ce qui revient
très fort en ce moment au niveau
capillaire oui quelle est la nouvelle
tendance qu'elle coupe de cheveux a eu
son championnat d'europe ce week-end
c'est un titre est convoqué que très
connoté qu'à gagner nicolas van der
kelen ce belge est le nouveau champion
d'europe de la coupe mulet ça revient
très très fort regardez regardez oui oui
quand même et bah écoute et ben on ne
savait pas où était raymond aujourd'hui
non mais c'est un poste important gap a
essayé
de me laisser d'abord cette coupe
typique des années 80 mais cette coupe
c'est avant tout un état d'esprit
anticonformiste afficha liberté à
l'autodérision
c'est pas bon mais c'est marrant et de
l'humour il n'en manque pas les
organisateurs de la première édition de
ce championnat d'europe c'était en
belgique en 2010 9 ils sont ravis
aujourd'hui de passer le relais aux
creusois ici à chenilles
[Applaudissements]
alors et chérie dernière question que
fait cet effet ils dansent tout nu merde
ils dansent tout nu alors dans ce cas
ils n'ont retenu que la réponse précise
stéphane plaza dans un clip qu'on a vues
sont aujourd'hui en hausse et une vidéo
sur un stade mais bon pour vous c'est un
clip
[Rires]
c'est un scoop people
voilà stéphane plaza nous a dévoilé son
intimité elle est incroyable cette ville
est oui stéphane plaza a lâché la rampe
et moi c'est comme ça que j'adore oui
regardez c'était valbuena je rappelle
qu'il est amoureux de vous défini il va
dire oui je lâche tout pour delphine
c'est vrai intérêt alors du coup
j'attends de voir la vidéo et puis après
on
toujours d'abord voir
cette culture le film
est ce que j'aime bien les qq oui un
beau fessier c'est important d'accord
bien sûr déjà donc on sait que voilà il
y en a pas mal d'entre vous qui sont
éliminés
[Musique]
l'extraordinaire c'est pas de place ici
j'ai personnellement j'adore chiots et
qui pourrait leur faire ça demain
personne
il a un beau petit cul c'était quoi la
légende la vidéo enfin où le but de la
vidéo du coup rien 60 et dans les îles
et sa rentrée dans les grosses têtes de
mariée voulais l'annoncer à voilà qu'est
simplement